This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Rob.
And I'm Sam.
Now, Sam, look into my eyes. You are feeling sleepy. Relax.
What's he doing, Rob? Trying to hypnotise me?
Well, since hypnotism is the topic of this programme, I thought I'd give it a try.
So, how do you feel, Sam? Are you under my spell?
Hmm, I don't think so, Rob. It's not so easy to put me into a hypnostic trance.
That's the word to describe the state of mind of someone who's been hypnotised and isn't completely in control.
Ah, you mean like those stage magicians who trick people into
clucking like a chicken or playing an imaginary violin.
Yes, some hypnotists make people do silly things for entertainment,
but hypnotism has real benefits as well. Curing phobias, for example.
Er, maybe so, but for other people, the very idea of a hypnotic trance is nonsense.
And even if hypnotism is real, why would you let a complete stranger inside your head?
Don't worry, Rob. I won't make you cluck like a chicken.
Oh, please don't. At least not before my quiz question, which is about a well-known 20th-century hypnotist.
One of the first Europeans to hypnotise people, this man became so famous that his name is forever
associated with hypnotic trances. But, who was he? Was it a Sigmund Freud, B. Franz Mesmer,
or C. Harry Houdini? Well, people want to quit smoking,
sometimes use a kind of therapy involving hypnotism. So maybe it's A. Sigmund Freud.
Okay, we'll find out if that's right at the end of the programme.
One question that's often asked is whether anyone can be hypnotised,
or are there people, maybe like you, Sam, who are less hypnotizable than others?
Professor Amiraz is a psychiatrist at the Brain Institute in Orange County, California.
According to him, there are two things which explain what makes one person more or less hypnotizable
than another. As he told BBC World Service programme, the wife actor.
And listen out for the first thing he mentions.
Initially, people thought that if you're very intelligent, you're likely to be less
suggestible. If you are male, you're likely to be less suggestible than if you're female.
These have been largely dismissed. In fact, it's about two things. First, absorption.
Your ability to get engrossed. In a particular activity, we all know people who are capable of
reading a book and losing track of time. We know the same thing about people who are watching a film
and beginning to cry, having all these emotional reactions, again, getting very much sucked into
the scene and being riveted. People often think you can be easily hypnotised if you are
suggestible or easily influenced by others. In fact, hypnotism is about two things.
Did you hear the first thing, Sam? Yes, it's getting absorbed. So absorbed that you lose track of time.
Become so occupied with something that you are unaware of the passing time.
And getting absorbed can also mean you get sucked into something.
Become involved in a situation when you do not want to be involved.
Stage hypnotists often speak in soothing, gentle ways to help this process of getting someone
absorbed or sacked in. But according to Professor Razz, there's a second important part to being
hypnotised. Attention. Listen to the definition of attention. Professor Razz gives to BBC World
Service Program the wife actor. The ability to get focused, to concentrate and hone in on particular
select pieces of information to the exclusion of others. Besides the relaxed,
dream-like feeling of being absorbed, what's also needed is the concentration to hone in on something.
In other words, to give it your full attention. What you hone in on could be the way the
hypnotist speaks, like how Rob said, look into my eyes at the beginning of the programme.
Or it could be some other object, like a moving finger, a pendulum or a swinging watch
that some hypnotists use. Well, I don't feel hypnotised or open.
But I'm certainly focused on one thing. My lunch. So come on, tell me. What's the correct answer to
the quiz question? Okay Sam, I asked you which hypnotist was so famous that his name became used
as a verb. And what did you say? I guess it was a Sigmund Freud. It was a good guess,
but the correct answer was B, a German doctor called Franz Mesmer. Of course. And the word
named after him was mesmerised to have your attention completely fixed so that you can't think
of anything else. Well, that might be a problem if you want to remember this vocabulary. So let's
recap the words we've learned, starting with trance, a state of consciousness in which you are not
completely aware or in control. Someone who is suggestible is easily influenced by other people.
When you lose track of time, you become so absorbed with something that you are unaware of time
passing. And you might get sucked in, become involved in a situation that you don't want to.
Hypnotism also depends on concentration and the ability to hone in on something, to give
something your full attention. Until you're mesmerised, you have your attention completely fixed
so that you cannot think of anything else. That's all for this hypnotic journey. Bye for now. Bye bye.